moi je suis les Verts au fond du café
et bientôt on va faire le bon pouvoir
ces images d'Édith Piaf sont inédites à
la télé française c'est la première fois
que vous les voyez la môme est en
concert en 1959 des archives retrouvées
et restaurées par l'Institut national de
l'audiovisuel le ballet des cœurs
[Musique]
dans un coin de la vie des liens qui
revient comment qu'ils puissent
qui se balance
[Musique]
d'image était probablement destinée au
magazine d'informations cinq colonnes à
la une diffusée sur la RTF à l'époque
Edith Piaf vient d'entamer une tournée
en France malgré un état de santé très
fragile Steve Normandin auteur d'Édith
Piaf l'icône méconnu revient sur cette
période tout le monde lui déconseille de
faire cette tournée et de plutôt ce
soigner et elle n'entend rien et donc
elle accepte de faire cette tournée et
on se rend vite compte que quelque chose
qui loge à tel point que les
journalistes tirent une sonnette
d'alarme qui va permettre fin aux
ordonnées d'arrêter et que vous sentiez
que vous avez que vous croyez avoir la
force de continuer vous désobéiriez à
votre médecin vous l'avez déjà fait
suicidaire par la presse en 1959 lors de
ce concert elle enchaîne les
interprétations à ses côtés ses
musiciens
les amandes d'un jour diffusés à la
télévision c'est une première mondiale à
sur Steve Normandin on n'a pas de
témoignages on n'a pas de traces on
était pleine collectionneurs à se poser
la question on aimerait bien voir les
amants d'un jour et bien aujourd'hui
c'est possible voici les premières
paroles
pour pouvoir rêver
et dans ce décor banane
[Musique]
il me semble encore les voir arriver
Edith Piaf est habité par sa chanson un
torchon à la main tous ceux qui ont vu
Piaf en spectacle
de voir Piaf utiliser son torchon et de
frotter le verre les photos nous donner
des indications mais vraiment qu'est-ce
qu'elle en fait et comment elle en joue
comme d'une femme qui travaille dans un
café et si toute la beauté de son
travail qui nous apparaît à l'écran et
c'est pour ça que ce film là me semble
de première importance
c'est un an par la main
réveillé
je veux chérubins portant le soleil ils
ont demandé d'une voix tant qu'il un
tout imposser mais après les amants d'un
jour Edith Piaf prolonge le plaisir avec
un autre morceau mythique
la foule la foule la chanson a déjà été
diffusée partiellement à la télé
française mais jamais en intégralité là
aussi c'est un inédit je revois la ville
en fait et en délire je suis focus le
soleil sous la joie et j'entends dans la
musique et les cris les rires qui est
que la terre bouddhiste autour de moi
puis vient le refrain
[Musique]
qui nous traîne nous entraîner
l'un contre l'autre nous
ne sommes encore et le flow sans effort
nous poussant enchaîner l'un et l'autre
et nous laisse tous deux
épanouirer heureux au total 35 minutes
d'interprétation des images
exceptionnelles retrouvées 60 ans après
la disparition d'Édith Piaf la môme est
morte le 10 octobre 1963 à Grasse d'une
rupture d'anévrisme
[Musique]